good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Tuesday that feels like
a Monday because it is a new year new
season it's the season of the sixth
that's right season six of the toast
starts right [ __ ] now hey Jax how you
doing during good so happy to be back
I'm so tempted to say that this is the
Monday is Monday of all time but it's a
Tuesday which is really throwing me
through a loop the fact that the whole
world decided that even though New
Year's day was on a Sunday like it's not
enough for us no dou we need a whole ass
another bank holiday on January 2nd was
really beautiful how we could come
together in that way and agree let's
talk about the banks the banks who did
this for us after taking and taking and
taking from us the banks finally gave
back and you know what
it needs to be spoken about I am
grateful I am honored I'm feeling
genuinely humbled me and Ben could not
get over yesterday how like we just had
this day everyone was probably returning
from travel to have this reset before
the new year is really I can't thank the
banks enough yeah I think it was really
nice how they did that plus it makes the
first week back a little easier it's a
four day work week gorgeous gorgeous
gorgeous gorgeous week and I'm just
feeling I'm really really excited to be
back on the toast I enjoyed my time off
but I was very much like in my house
brow era and I'm just excited to be back
to like being a working mom and doing
the show which I love and talking to my
girl like I haven't spoken to you
literally all year I haven't spoken to
you this year you know what I do think
it's for the best like we have so much
to catch up on on this episode and I
also am feeling refreshed I'm tan thank
the Lord I
was talking about before we ended last
year that I really was in need of like a
break I was feeling like super burnt out
I felt like doing the podcast like I was
scraping the bottom of the barrel to
like be funny and interesting and now
I've just like lived two weeks without
sharing and I'm ready I'm just gonna
spread my legs and share yeah your cup
run it's over
my cup run is over of things to talk
about first of all I do think I finally
decided on what my New Year's resolution
is
and this morning when I was like gearing
up for how I was going to phrase it on
the show I realized I think I literally
have had this resolution in one way or
the other like for the last four years
if I went back and watched every January
one episode I think I would it's some
version of this because
I think a few years ago my resolution
was like to say no to life
um like I felt like I was just always
saying yes and like doing things that I
didn't want to be doing so for the last
couple of years like I've been saying no
to life and I've decided that this year
I'm going to say yes to life like I'm
gonna say like I'm always being invited
places like I never go I'm so [ __ ]
lazy
I'm gonna say yes to life this year
wow
okay
what like there's just a reason why you
were saying no and I think it's because
before that you were saying yes so I
think for you like you you can't find a
balance and it's always going to be like
I'm either saying oh yes or all no but
why couldn't you just be like more yeses
but not all yeses because that's how you
burn out then you'll wind up doing stuff
that you don't want to do okay your
negative toxic energy for my positive
resolution like [ __ ] I just think you're
putting I think you're just like putting
too much pressure on yourself
no I'm I need to say yes to life like
I'm getting I only have so many years
left in my 20s like and I don't want to
talk about how I really only have like a
year and a half left yeah I am going to
be my best to life like I'm going to LA
this weekend I'm going to the 49ers game
like I'm saying yes to life [ __ ] I feel
like I
I have so many like wonderful
opportunities presented to me and I'm
always just like no I'll stay home and I
love staying home but I felt like I've
stayed at home stayed home a lot
especially with covid like this is my
year it's my year and I won't let your
toxicity penetrate my year okay I'm just
trying to tell you like I think that you
were like fine before I think that when
something is worth going to you always
go you really do I think you're just
being like a little CR self-critical
when you're doing great sweetie and
you're you're do you always do like the
big cool stuff but you say no to like
you know the dumb [ __ ] which
I think it's okay but fine I'm
supporting you I just feel like I got
comfortable saying no like a little too
comfortable you know I get that I get
that
so I'm gonna say yes to life did you
come up with a resolution I didn't
because I finally on the second to last
day of the year completed my 15-year
resolution of getting my driver's
license that has literally been my New
Year's resolution every single year it's
huge and I'm feeling accomplished and
I'm gonna enjoy this moment and my
accomplishment and then I'm gonna
regroup and think about okay what's next
for me like what but like I have
recently learned to do a lot of things
that I never really thought I was going
to be doing like driving like cooking
and now I need to kind of set new goals
but I think that makes sense like I'm 30
like my life is changing maybe it's like
gardening I don't [ __ ] know I would I
think gardening is so you and I agree
with you like it's important to
acknowledge the moment that you're in
because all we have is this moment and
really you know what they say about
tomorrow
tomorrow's unspoken
yes yes it is history
that song and that album I feel like
people don't talk about prism enough
Katy Perry he's like I think it was Katy
Perry's like really like it was she's
had beautiful songs before yada yada but
that was her first like true work of art
that like the whole album was a
masterpiece I [ __ ] love that album
well I disagree with that because like I
think Teenage Dream was a masterpiece
too the problem with prison it prison
prison
is that the songs that she chose for the
singles were the worst songs on the
album you can't think that's very Taylor
Swift no and no no no and so no no I'm
obsessed with prism it's literally one
of my favorite albums of all time and
like some of my favorite songs of all
timer from that album but I'm telling
you why it didn't get like more play
from the late people is because they
heard you know like what was that song
about a birthday or like International
okay
every day I love that song like the
songs that she chose for the singles
were so corny that people just assumed
the album was corny but they were
missing like the beauty by the grace of
God excuse me
and I actually kind of like fun fact
about me was I saw the prism world tour
at Madison Square Garden and it was it
was so insane like it was that Katy
Perry level of like crazy outfits
confetti lights but with this art it was
really beautiful I'm so happy that you
said yes to that
and it actually was my birthday when um
you made it like your birthday every day
and when she sings that song she like
found someone in the audience whose
birthday was but my seats were like so
far back she was never gonna see me I
was like screaming I'm like it's my
birthday Katie she didn't care
I'm sorry but just make sure to make it
like your birthday every day that's also
a good New Year's resolution yeah except
that you'll be insufferable insufferable
by the end of the year but no Honestly
by like February I don't want to hang
out with anyone who's making it like
their birthday every day 100 so we
caught up on a lot over the patreon so
if you're here looking for you know
Yellowstone Recaps Emily in Paris Recaps
Real Housewives of Miami Recaps the
Kardashian Christmas party like there
wasn't that much that happened
thankfully while we were off in terms of
Pop Culture but Jackie and I read and
watched a lot and we recapped it all on
the pop culture catch up which was our
fourth episode for December I think if
you were a patreon member this month
you're feeling really grateful because
the patreon really came in we had I
think three or four episodes
release while the toast was off Jackie's
entire journey to getting her license
that Vlog is up people are kind of like
you know there's like Whispers there's
Oscar buzz for the editing I actually I
like I got choked up at the end Jackie
did this really beautiful edit about
just kind of the the progress you've
made from being driven around by Me by
Ben to finally being in the driver's
seat it was really beautiful yeah I did
a little Montage at the end of the Vlog
and I am hearing some of that buzz too
it's like this ringing in my ear it's
like for the short film category at the
Oscars I'm no big and obviously I don't
do it for the accolades of course not I
just I the art honestly like it came
over me you know I couldn't stop making
that art you know I do want to share a
fun fact about me like I do it for the
accolades and I want let's normalize
doing it for the accolades okay but if
that's true if that's true that you do
it for the accolades then like you must
be really
because we don't get any accolades no
but accolades like I don't need to be
nominated for like an iHeartRadio
podcast award like just accolades from
the fans like I I just I I would be
remiss if I didn't start the year out on
an honest note like I am doing this
actively for the accolades like keep
telling me you love me keep subscribing
keep all that energy if somebody wants
to nominate me for an iHeartRadio
podcast award even though our podcast is
not produced by iHeartRadio therefore we
don't stand the chance it's okay I I I'm
doing it actively for the accolades I
just I wanted everyone to know that okay
so give her as many accolades as you can
think of if you work at the Shorties the
webies yeah People's Choice she loves an
Accolade I I feel like I really [ __ ]
up with the Shorties
you did you know what um can you add
that to my life's biggest regret that
year that is a story that's an instance
where you should have said yes and
that's a story where like I physically
my body physically connocaves and
cringes when I think about the time that
I was nominated for a shorty award
rsvp'd yes to the uh ceremony that was
being live streamed Shay Mitchell came
out and announced the award and I
actually won and my ass I was literally
taking a nap
okay I know and then like people were
tweeting me like this clip Shay Mitchell
was like girl with no job Claudia ashrae
and silence
silence because I was I think a I had
forgotten the event was that day B like
I was like I'm not gonna win and see I
was like they're definitely not gonna
announce my category on the stream it'll
be like one of the losers that gets
announced like during the pre-show so
never in my wildest dreams said I think
it would be such a
an official Affair it was like a it was
a full-blown award ceremony that would
have gotten up and made a speech do you
think that because of that like our
Awards Karma has been off 100
100 I'm so sorry I took you down with me
no that's okay
I'm going down too as stated I don't do
it for the accolades
um well I do right so it's really just
your cross to bear let's also talk about
how this is the first episode of our
sixth season of the toast which is so
crazy your girls have been podcasting
together since 2017.
season six
every time we advance into a new season
I feel so like we're so legit you know
yeah it's nice to get those numbers up
because on the one hand like with the
internet in general I feel like you know
the more years you've been doing it the
more irrelevant you are so true but with
podcasting it's really not like that I
feel like the more years you've been
doing it and the more you're relevant
it's more of an accomplishment I
completely agree so it's pretty cool and
six is a nice number six
sex
it is a good number and it's a good day
and it's a good year it's going to be a
great year I hope everyone gets
everything that they want for themselves
this year whether that's inner peace a
promotion a baby whatever it is I hope
everyone gets what they want invitations
to things in which they will say yes so
yes I think part of me making my
resolution saying yes to to life is also
a manifestation and a putting out into
the world to have things to say yes to
but I do think the more that you go to
the more you get invited to because
they're like oh there's Claudia she's oh
she's down not like that's not bother
inviting her she won't come and I think
part of
um like a real impetus and motivation
behind this resolution is to go out and
have my photograph taken to replace some
of the absolutely abysmal photos that
exist of me online whether it's Google
or Getty like there are just too many
ugly pictures of me and I feel like I'm
I'm kind of like hitting like a physical
peak right now
um and I need these photos to exist in
perpetuity so that when I get fat and
ugly again I will
have these to look at now that's
something I can get behind I know you
can and I can understand I also think a
good New Year's resolution for both of
us this year is to try and limit our
negative self-talk like oh I agree I
can't because I can't hear it when I
talk about myself because like yeah like
I'm a big ugly loser
um but like when when you say stuff
about yourself I'm like stop like that's
literally Harry's mom like no one
somebody has something to say to Harry's
[ __ ] mom I'll choke them you know
what I know I know what you mean too and
I know that's how we like talk and I'm
just like Oh I'm a big fat loser it's
also just our brand of humor like it is
but then sometimes I'll like hear it and
I'm like it makes me sad I'm like you
shouldn't talk about yourself that way
and I honestly I probably wouldn't talk
about someone else that way no oh my God
not even someone I hate I mean something
yeah maybe big fat loss but think about
like when I see it through the lens of
like you being Harry's mom and then like
you call yourself ugly it's literally
impossible physically genetically
impossible for you to be ugly because
you gave birth to Harry do you know what
I mean I do
like you honestly are nothing short of
perfection because you gave birth to
Harry oh my goodness it's proof positive
talk I know like don't catch me next
week like I will be back to my negative
self but like let's just pretend for a
week that like it's good to lead with
your best foot forward and I think I
could say the same to you as Harry's
Auntie a hundred percent someone's gonna
talk trash about how he's empty right
right not on my watch not on my [ __ ]
watch so I think that's a good um
resolution as well I think Claudia
that's beautiful thanks I'm feeling very
positive I went on vacation and it
wasn't it was a vacation that felt like
a real vacation you know I think when I
go on trips I'm so used to
um doing like long weekends and cramming
everything into you know three or four
days and like getting drunk I really was
I can't remember the last time I took a
Beach vacation for a week like there was
so much time I relaxed I stayed in I
went out I swam I read like it was a
true relaxing vacation
um and I really needed that I'm so happy
for you everyone wants to hear all about
your trip I went to Belize which um I
believe I stated previously was in South
America and I just want to tell everyone
that it's not it's right underneath
Mexico and I was surprised to find that
while the language native language is
creole pretty much everyone speaks
Spanish so you know me me like bilingual
Elgato and la biblioteca I was feeling
really I was feeling like Claudia you
know I do know so it's at North America
or Central America
such important questions you ask and I
feel like it could be one of those
places that's like on the board or just
like kind of how Israel is is like Asia
and it's in Asia Africa and Europe
so I believe it is Central America
okay
I'll just Google it
but I went to San Pedro so we flew into
Belize City airport and we took like a
tiny plane to San Pedro which is one of
the islands with lots of hotels it was
really beautiful but by the way it's
also like in the Caribbean I don't know
it's it's so funny it just said North
Central America
okay so it was intentionally confusing
yeah so I think it's like in between
yeah
it was great yeah it was great I got to
spend so much time with counselor which
is I was a counselor the counselor is so
cool like I know it was it was really an
honor to be by her side for a week like
for real do you think that you guys got
closer
definitely I asked her the same question
she said yeah
she said the bond was strengthened the
bond was definitely strengthened like I
feel so good entering 2023 like when it
comes to the counts ugh I'm so jealous I
know we I'll have to get the counts now
that I'm like so close with her
um I'll have to get her down to Florida
and you have to get her to like be nice
to me like if you can influence her no
I'm like I'm like I'm like friends with
the popular girls now and like you're
the geek and like I'll get the popular
girl to like you you're so good to me
like that I'm so generous you really are
yeah no she said the bond was
strengthened I was asking her how like
her Bonds were strengthening or
weakening with anyone on the trip and
what did she say she said I actually
think her bond with Ben was definitely
weakened they were like
what she said it was neither
strengthened nor weakened no like
they're Ben Ben actually referred to
Margot like we were just having a
conversation he referred to Marco as his
sister and I'm like wait Maddie's not
here like I forget that they're
technically like you know brother and
sister-in-law but they were acting like
such brother sister like mocking each
other like any of them like they both
were reverting to actual 11 year olds
and it was it was actually funny that's
funny snitch really beefs with the
brother-in-laws like she has the same
relationship with Zach where they're
always at each other's throats and I'm
just saying you guys you guys no and
like I'm over here being like The
Peacemaker right that's so you
so me she said her bond with Emily
strengthened even though she didn't know
if that was possible but that's good
mostly means like there was no Cabin
Fever which is good no which is good
yeah no uh yesterday when it was like
our day to reset like I slept till noon
I call Margo she's out to lunch I'm like
oh yeah she's like Emily I'm like you
could see someone for lunch that you
just spent a week with I could never
unless
sometimes you spend so much time with
someone and you're like I can't I need
to spend more time together like yeah
where it wasn't enough we're so close I
wish she ever felt that way about us but
we'll get there we're just I have I have
my foot in the door
oh wow you have the connection I got the
hook up
sick oh my God and we haven't been able
to really even like recap how our most
recent episode before the year ended we
had on like a lifelong guest of ours A
Dream Olivia Culpo and just such a great
way to end the year
such a great way to end the year I
finished watching the show the copos you
guys it's so good it's my new Comfort
show Claude you've got to watch all the
episodes I know and it's so real like I
feel like I really know like what's
going on in their lives and how they
feel about stuff yeah like the sister
beef like they're they really weren't
holding anything back they like gave it
all to this first season of the show and
it's so good I love that love that and
now Liv is like in the Niners gang
oh yeah so I become like a really big
49ers fan over the break that's what I
was doing I don't know if you know
they're like on a streak they are
they've won nine games and that's like
the first time since the 70s that's
happened to the 49ers
I'm actually going to the game this
Sunday in San Francisco
um because I'm already gonna be out on
the west coast because I'm saying yes to
life and hopefully they're gonna get
their 10th and I can see all my friends
like Kristen and Kyle and Olivia and
Christian just like the crew Chris and
Kyle Claudia Christian Olivia Barack on
Claude you know that's what they say
right no what does that mean because
their new quarterback I think he was
like a sub for the big one Jimmy
Garoppolo it might be awesome that's
another thing that's another thing it's
like all the really [ __ ] hot guys are
on the 49ers no and they're all like
wifed up and they love their wives no I
tell me what's up
tell me what's hotter than like a hot
guy who loves his wife nothing like the
kiddles have you stalked the kiddles yet
I'm not familiar you're in for a treat
kisses his wife before every game
obsessed with his wife like you're
obsessed with your wife I'm obsessed
with you
yeah
yeah it's just good energy and I and all
the Wags get like so dolled up and like
um in reworked Niners like like jerseys
but they're like high fashion and it I
don't really study like all of the Wags
of every team but I feel like there's a
culture there where it's like where the
Wags and we're getting so [ __ ] Glam
for our men and like we are obsessed
with football and the Niners no like
you're gonna catch me being a wag this
Sunday and like I feel like we actually
have a lot of Wags who listen to the
toes like if any 49ers Wags are
listening like I'll be at the game like
come find me maybe bring me like a
bedazzled Jersey and like a costume you
have to wear red cloth they all wear red
for the Niners of course I actually have
like a a juice check Jersey that was
like given to me by Kyle and it is
signed and I'll probably wear that oh
that's cool yeah and like maybe like
with like tights and like I'll look like
a [ __ ] you know I also another
resolution like I'm ready to start
dressing like a [ __ ] like I only have
so many horror years left
and I'm gonna do it
I love that for you let's start showing
tits like I showed my arms on New Year's
Eve and I haven't showed my arms in
public
since the CMA Awards and I only showed
one arm then and then before that it was
five years so now that I've like I'm
slowly like dipping my foot in the pond
and like getting comfortable like I'm
gonna start showing leg chest neck not
today I'm wearing literally a turtleneck
yeah and we're also matching today we
didn't even plan it oh we look so cute
look at us um we're being so supportive
we also have a big story today
um
football related yeah because everyone
is talking about Demar Hamlin so we're
going to talk about that we're also
going to catch up a little bit on some
stories we weren't able to recap there
wasn't a lot that happened over the
break thank you that's the relief like
there's really not a ton that happened
over the break that like we have to do
like this whole sweeping catch up except
with each other you know I feel like I
don't know anything about you anymore
um well here's what you need to know I'm
saying yes to life okay
I'm stopping the negative self-talk okay
and I'm dressing like a [ __ ]
I literally love that for you
it's gonna be exciting so exciting I if
you want to know about me I have my
driver's license oh huge I'm a driver
now
Harry claps now oh you're kidding me no
and you know what we watched Miss Rachel
for the first time oh I have an update
for Miss Rachel after your story we
watch Miss Mitchell For the First Time
like three days ago and then yesterday
he started like clapping but I've never
like done clapping with him it never
like occurred to me and like straight up
he got it from Miss Rachel from that one
day
okay I have an update on Miss Rach
because like you guys know earlier like
maybe three four months ago we
went viral on Tick Tock for talking
about Miss Rach we were joking and like
people did not think it was funny and
then we became like Miss Rich haters
which were [ __ ] not people were just
like putting their negative you know
thoughts on us and I didn't even realize
but I was scrolling tick tock on the
beach I didn't realize that when that
video went viral Miss Rachel commented
on it and followed me she thought it was
funny she did like crying Emoji like
Miss Rachel has a [ __ ] sense of humor
okay
wow healing Miss right just a toaster
I wonder what like Miss Rach gets up to
in her personal time
you know because you know what I teach
her about Mr H what
how much money she makes like for real
like that's what keeps me up at night of
course of course I have a Channel with
hundreds of millions of views yes but
like I feel like you can conceive like
if you thought of like other YouTubers
who have big channels I'm sure she's
breaking it in what I really want to
know is like why she doesn't have a show
on Nickelodeon yet like why hasn't
someone scooped her up I imagine they
try to but like maybe she's stuck to her
guns I don't know I think she's I think
she's scrupled I don't think she wants
to sell out to the man I think she loves
what she does I think she makes a really
good living from it I don't know if like
Fame and excess wealth I feel like she's
kind of like a granola-y like socialist
that's like the vibe I get you know yeah
I get a granola Vibe too it's definitely
the overalls
um it's the overalls yeah I know for
sure but I feel like yes she doesn't
want to sell out to the man but I
imagine when she makes these videos like
it takes her so long because it's like
all this green screen like you know it's
like it would be like if we tried to
make a video like on iMovie no 100 and
so I wonder why she doesn't just like
you know out Source some of that work
and so that would be easier for her she
could focus on the content like focus on
the kids and I think she loves the work
like I think she loves it shoves the
process and she's always now I follow
her back on Tick Tock she's always like
stitching and do wedding people sharing
their videos uh the impact of Miss
Rachel and it brings her so much joy to
see like kids saying mama who were like
delayed in their speech I think she
loves what she does and
how lucky is she yeah it's the best it's
the best
so shout out to miss Rach
Stick it to the Man She I heard she'd
Stick it to the maniosis I heard that
too and you know what I heard is the
best best cure for sticky to maniosis
what liquid IV because the new year is
here and there's no better way to kick
off 2023 than by making sure you're
feeling like your best self and saying
yes to life liquid IV is the category
winning hydration brand fueling fueling
your well-being and their hydration
multiplier is one product you're missing
in your daily routine so it's one stick
that gives you five essential vitamins
and two times faster hydration than
water alone you can use it first thing
in the morning before a workout when you
feel run down after a long night and on
Long flights if you're feeling like New
Year's fatigue you were traveling or
you're hungover start off the new year
healthy and feeling good and having your
vitamins and your vital nutrients with
liquid IV one stick of liquid IV it's a
powder you put it into 16 ounces of
water and it'll hydrate you two times
faster and more efficiently than water
alone it contains five essential
vitamins like B3 B5 B6 B12 and vitamin C
with three times the electrolytes of
traditional sports drinks it's made with
premium ingredients it is also non-GMO
and it's free from gluten dairy and soy
so this year if you are wanting to take
care of yourself take care of your
family just stock up on liquid IV it's
so good to always have in the house
because sometimes you know like
dehydration or a migraine or a hangover
like it just hits you so fast and you're
not prepared but if you always have just
like a pack of liquid IV they have such
good flavors if you always have one in
your house like you are going to be set
up for Success you can get liquid IV
bulk bulk nationwide at Costco so if
you're a Costco girl they just throw it
in
um or you can get 20 off you can shop
online at liquid iv.com and our code
toast will get you that 20 off anything
you order when you shop better hydration
today promo code is toast at liquid
iv.com
thank you so much for that so I just
tried to copy you and put my headphones
like over my hair like how you do
because I always put my hair behind my
ears but I feel like like Sydney White
when Amanda Bynes was in that movie and
she's like covered in hair
let's talk about Amanda bynes's hair
let's talk about the wig
what the [ __ ] was that
and why couldn't she be without those
pieces in the front it's so amazing to
me how like film and TV like they have
access to the world's best special
effects hair makeup and there's so many
movies I can think of where like a
character is wearing a wig and she
literally looks like you know she's
wearing like a Shadle and she lives in
Brooklyn like I literally cannot watch I
forget which Twilight movie it is when
yeah uh Kristen Stewart is wearing the
craziest [ __ ] wig that's like not I
see girls on Tick Tock who lay down like
lace front wigs 40 times better than how
they did for Kristen Stewart in that
film like what the [ __ ] yeah I don't
know but I just feel like I feel like
it feels weird to have the headphones
over my hair you like that
so when we switch to our remote setup
which let's keep in mind was entirely
your fault for moving and leaving me I
had to make do like my hair and I feel
like some people might my hair is my
protector like my hair is my security
like you can never catch me with my hair
behind my ears like my hair is always
going to be in front of my face except
when you wear your 1989 sweatshirt
except when I wear my 1989 sweatshirt I
will throw my hair on a claw clip but
like for for the most part like you will
not catch me without my hair like full
and so the fact that we switched to
remote like that's not going to change
my protective hair so I had to make do
and yes I put my headphones on top of my
hair because you moved to Florida that's
really why okay no but you look good I
always have my hair behind my ears how
does it look what do you think it looks
cute but like why don't you put more
hair in front okay it looks cute but it
just feels weird I feel like that's cute
well so for me like if my hair is not
looking like Hagrid and it's not all
over the front of my face and I don't
want it
you actually look gorgeous right now you
should leave it but it's giving Sydney
White right like cover just those pieces
well you know the kids on Tick Tock call
those two pieces that you leave in the
front of your head they call them [ __ ]
strands
so I guess you'll be wearing those this
year when I show tits arms legs and ass
yeah in your horror era in my horror era
for sure and why do they call them [ __ ]
strands
the thing about me is I don't ask
questions I just follow the trends and
that's why I'm a follower and a loser
negative self-talk
we need a button negative self-talk like
you need a button we need a lot of
buttons do you think they make a
negative self-talk button and so that
they sell on Amazon I think they make a
button that you can write on top of that
says Okay a customizable button work
survey yeah I'm sure you can get one on
Etsy
another resolution like gotta shop more
on Etsy like every time like I see
something cool like on Tick Tock you're
like let's turn this Etsy Shop like I
need to go on Etsy yeah I agree with
that like sometimes it never occurs to
me to like look for what I want on Etsy
like I was looking for um
those of the hardware for Harry's
dresser and I just got like some crap on
Amazon but then I saw a friend of mine
she had posted like she did cust uh she
got like new hardware for her baby's
dresser and she got them on Etsy and
they were like little animals ornate oh
that's [ __ ] cute like Amazon could
never Amazon can never and I feel like
in order to offset like how much money I
spent on Amazon I also need to be
supporting like local shops that sell on
Etsy agreed that's a good resolution
shop local I can't live like this with
my hair one second
um well while Jackie's doing that I'll
just tell you guys how beautiful
standing Inspire oh thank God what'd you
say about me no she's talking about
myself oh okay great one thing about me
is like you never have to worry about me
talking about someone else because I'm
always talking about myself it's true
it's like so reassuring to be your
friend yeah if you're my like close
personal friend and you're listening
like just know like actually this is
such a lie let me be honest if you're my
close personal friend like you should
know like I definitely talk [ __ ] about
you but it doesn't change like how I
feel about you like I love you but like
we're all human beings and some of the
[ __ ] you do is annoying and I'm not
gonna tell you so I'm just gonna tell
someone else I don't think you really
talk that much [ __ ] about your close
personal friends unless they did
something like weird and art out of
character you know I guess yeah but if
their character was weird they wouldn't
be your close personal friend
so true
um well I feel like we should dive in
what do you think yeah I think so along
the way we continue to catch up share
what's new with each other was there
anything else we didn't catch up on
I don't think so just you know it's a
new year new us that's so true and
season six that's really what you have
to know that's what you have to know
it's the season of the six and I
oh are you snitch now you've been
hanging out with snitch every time like
I've been posting on social media like
season six the toast I cannot stop
saying stick season because that's
Mario's favorite song it's such a good
song yeah I was listening to it while I
was driving yeah because I drive now you
know you're gonna be you know those like
kids in high school who like got their
um license because they like were born
in January whatever so they get it
before everyone else and they got like
keys and they just like walk around like
with their keys like oh like I was
driving today and then like does anybody
need me to drive them anywhere like that
I saw the tick tock it was yeah that's
you the girl with like the extension
rings of her hair yeah and the white
lipstick Burt's Bees and the keys I mean
I'm never gonna stop jingling my keys
like who could who could I do have to
get a car though that's next that's well
you better do that uh wait for me
because I want to come
oh really why don't you come on down
what I was thinking yeah and I'm sure
this is a business that exists so if you
know about it like let me know but I
feel like when buying a car you need
like a realtor for cars like someone
like I could tell them what I'm looking
for they have knowledge and expertise
because I know like what I need in a car
but those exist what's it called a
husband
no but he doesn't know like every car
that's out there every make and model
like sure there needs to be like some
sort of broker who like helps you yes
but then it's just like more red tape
more you have to pay them a fee like
it's just true it's true but like I need
an expert and then I say like I want
this this and this and they say well
these cars would be best for that well
you know what I feel like people on
social media like have become like the
car mom if you're a mom like looking for
different cars she'll help you find one
in different price ranges I feel like
there's lots of different people on
social media like if you're looking for
a sports car yes but I will say that
like and I love the car mom and I've
watched all of her videos but she makes
every car look amazing so I'm like so
which one do I get right I actually
spoke to her and she endorsed the card
that we did get she thought it was a
great choice fabulous you love to get
approval the car mom stamp of approval
exactly
so without without further
do oh my God I have to tell you about
bruta did it do because last night
something so we had a scare
he Shapiro we were at the Shapiro's uh
they were grilling Shapiro walks in with
like this plate of grilled chicken that
like smells so good Bruno got so excited
he jumped off the couch and he landed
badly and he landed and he like cried
out oh my God oh my God oh my God we
were freaking and then he started
walking with a limp like right after and
he was like crying a little and couldn't
walk and I was like oh my God like he I
might have Twisted zinc or whatever like
I'm gonna have to take him to the vet
today
um but then within the next like few
minutes he started walking properly
again he just need to walk it off but
wow it was scary stuff
Theo spent the entire week we were in
Belize with Ben's parents Theo's
favorite people on the planet and they
went to a New Year's Eve party at their
friend's house and they brought the O
because they the friends had a dog and
they were like yeah of course bring Theo
and Theo like laying on the couch with
everyone while they were doing 10 9 8 7
6 it was so cute then I found out later
Theo jumped on the table and got three
shrimp cocktails
nice
yeah Thea broke his cash root I'm always
proud of the boys when they get
something good you know as long as it's
not something that they can't eat like
I'm happy right like a chocolate or
grapes yeah yeah an onion right yeah I
don't know if onions like majorly toxic
like chocolate is like one lick and
you're dead no that's not true
real chocolate okay who eats real
chocolate no yeah thank God I never have
like cacao lying around I just have like
[ __ ] Hershey's it doesn't even have real
chocolate he would have to eat so much
Hershey's yeah so much but like you know
I uh Bruno recently had like two
Halloween sized Hershey bars almost I
left them out yeah he's crazy and he was
fine he's [ __ ] quick it doesn't mean
you should do it no do you have a little
bit of buffer
I'm so glad Bruno's okay it was just a
scare especially it was just a scare
especially if it's milk chocolate that's
why I don't eat dark chocolate even
though I love it yeah no I love cacao
that has like no sugar and no taste but
I just can't feel for Theo I don't keep
it in the house I couldn't dare wouldn't
Dane
anyways Bruno's doing well thank you
everyone I just wanted to share that
because it was jarring he was for sure
it was too much
pathetic yeah
so now without further uh did it did it
do
here are the fast side stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your toast
sorry I guess no how's this here are the
fast side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and say yes to life
that's gorgeous I wasn't paying
attention till the end and I was like of
course
yeah it's muscle memory
where is such muscular girls we're so
muscular like we're swole as [ __ ] so I
mean I went to the gym
you did and if you want to hear about it
listen to the patreon episode because
Claudia kind of needed to be even though
like no self-talk Claudia needs to be
roasted for going to the gym after a
lifetime of roasting people who go to
the gym on vacation
no that's definitely true
and we talked through it we talked
through it like I was obviously going
through something don't worry I'm back
like I'm not going to the gym again it
was obviously just like a low point in
my life thanks for checking in as stated
though there's a difference between
going to the gym and going to the gym on
vacation
100 even people who go to the gym
regularly don't do it on vacation
100 but you were hanging out with the
toxic spatula it's so true she's so
[ __ ] toxic yeah
I guess it's time to get into the
stories
only if the stories are brought to you
by Legacy box
they are
Legacy box is a super simple mail-in
service that has all of your videotapes
camcorder tapes film reels and old
pictures converted to perfectly
preserved digital files plus Legacy box
is an industry leader and has helped
over a million customers Safeguard their
past it's the simplest way to preserve
your precious memories and check off a
New Year's resolution what's your New
Year's resolution if you're like most of
us there's a box of your family's most
treasured home movies and photos tucked
into a closet that you've been meaning
to preserve but weren't sure where to
start well Legacy box is where you
should start and it makes checking this
off your to-do list super easy simply
send your legacy box filled with home
movies and photos and you'll get back
digital copies that can be easily
enjoyed shared and organized it's like
magic it's such an easy process to do
Legacy box keeps you updated along the
way when we did it we got emails every
time there was an update I think was
maybe over the course of like 12 emails
or like you've arrived they're being
processed and when it ships like you get
updates on the whole process and it's
really something like I feel like
everyone's meaning to do but doesn't do
it makes a great gift for someone but
also something for yourself if one of
your resolutions is to like clean out
your basement do do this because it's so
important and you could be one flood
away from losing all of your childhood
memories so whatever you got we were you
know VHS girls so we sent those in just
do it okay
uh kick off the New Year by rescuing
your family's most Cherished Memories
visit legacybox.com toast to take
advantage of this exclusive offer that's
legacybox.com toast Legacy Legacy
boxbox.com
t-o-a-s-t to take advantage of our
exclusive offer you can uh get the offer
now and send it in when you're ready so
you don't have to do it immediately
thank you so much mclartia you're
welcome okay our first story is the big
story of the day and it's such sad
distressing news Buffalo Bills have
confirmed that Demar Hamlin suffered a
cardiac arrest playing the Cincinnati
Bengals last night the Buffalo Bill
safety Demar Hamlin went into cardiac
arrest during the Monday night football
game against the Bengals the team
officially confirmed via social media he
still remains in critical condition they
said Demar Hamlin suffered a cardiac
arrest following a hit in our game
versus the Bengals his heartbeat was
restored on the field and he was
transferred to the UC Medical Center for
further testing and treatment he is
currently sedated and listed in critical
condition
this was so crazy because if you were
watching the game like the series of
events it was all televised yeah he was
tackled like really hard
he stood up
and then collapsed like it was so scary
to see
um
and his friends and family are like
asking people not to share the video
because it's obviously like really
distressing
um and I just feel like this is
you know it took the NFL like an hour to
call the game the game never the game
didn't resume it was an important game
whatever playoffs who cares
um it took them an hour to make that
decision and I just feel like and I I
see um Kelly Stafford talk about this a
lot she's a podcast and her husband
plays in the NFL it's like she doesn't
say this these are my words but it's
like the NFL's like real lack of
um
care when it comes to the safety of
their players like you know CTE and all
that stuff and they're not playing on
real grass and it's harder when they hit
their head and
there's you know the wives and just like
the players are like always you know
campaigning for like changes to be made
and I feel like the NFL is so stubborn
and like there should be a wake-up call
for everyone it's so sad and I'm so glad
he's
he was in critical condition and I think
a lot of people thought like
that he literally died on the field yeah
um so I'm glad he's I think he's getting
he's in critical condition still they
were able to revive his heartbeat on the
field but he is in the hospital in
critical condition so it's not clear
what's going to happen from here it's so
sad and like the NFL's priorities are so
[ __ ] I know it's a crazy playoff game
who [ __ ] cares who [ __ ] cares I
mean
like so often do players get hurt on the
field and it's just like protocol you
get them par for the course and you
continue on with the game which I I
always think is so weird anyway but this
was I think something unlike people have
ever seen what's crazy is like for
something like this to happen is so
jarring to be there but like
millions of people were just home
watching watching the ball and like saw
this out of nowhere and I think it was
really really jarring Zach was watching
and he came in he was like explaining to
me what was going on and I was like oh
my God
and yeah I hear you that like the
concept that like people get injured and
like we just go on with the game is like
weird but I think like certain injuries
like uh you know and sprained ankle or
you twist your knee like things like
that are expected when you're a
professional athlete but like something
is serious what is it cardiac arrest
like
that's where like you just stop the game
like you just stop the game no but I
think it's I think it was it's like they
don't
it's hard for them to make that call
considering like they are always you
know injuries and they go right so uh
obviously this is a much more serious
injury than what's typical in the end
it's like in a typical injury you know
the an ambulance doesn't drive onto the
field and there's no CPR like this was
obviously very different yes yeah
so I mean everybody is just football
fans and not like the whole country is
country on pause just like waiting to
hear how he's doing I mean he has a a
charity toy drive that he had been um
promoting recently and like it's had
millions of donations yeah since this
happened and I think people are just
like really rallying around him like
praying for him all the Wags that I do
follow her just like this is every
football family's nightmare nightmare
and we're all just hoping for a good
outcome
right and the fact that it's every
football family's nightmare like is a
problem yeah but from what I saw like
and from I think what uh the
sportscasters were saying like it's a
clean tackle you know yeah right no the
the person who did it I'm sure oh my God
he's having the worst day of his life he
didn't technically do anything wrong I
see [ __ ] like that all the time I saw
that Ben was showing me the thing and
I'm like oh it looks like a tackle it
wasn't like a crazy illegal or
so I don't know he maybe he landed weird
I don't know right or something was
going on with him but I think that the
tackle itself was not
anything bigger or stronger than what's
typical no but I think the typical
tackle like is it's flawed like you
shouldn't be able
no human being can withstand that
multiple times in an hour
I know but that's literally the game no
I know so you're saying cancel the game
I'm not saying cancel the game I'm
saying like I don't know I just feel
like they could be doing more like CTE
is like a real problem yes yeah for
people who played football long term
like concussions and and like just
there's problems yeah there's problems I
have no answers I'm just pointing out
problems yeah and I think it highlights
like that as a separate issue though
that's not what this is is about no
because it wasn't head trauma it was
cardiac chest yeah
so I don't really know what happened but
I'm really like I hope he's okay it's so
so sad yeah so sad
oh okay Switching gears to a little
recap news from while we were off Kim
Kardashian is hitting the podcast
circuit
she spoke with Angie Martinez and went
on the IRL podcast she also went on
Gwyneth Paltrow's goop podcast yes um
but I think the big one and the first
one was her going on Angie Martinez's
podcast and she talks about you know a
lot of the stuff that's going on with
her Kanye I didn't listen to goop I
didn't know Balenciaga
yeah I didn't listen to the group one
because I think the Angie Martinez one
was like the one where she addresses
everything in the group one was more
about like motherhood and business and
great I'll listen to it another time
um so I thought it was really
interesting first of all that she went
on a podcast I was like I'm not I
haven't heard of Angie Martinez podcast
it seemed like
um it wasn't going to be like a Diane
Sawyer hard-hitting it was very much
like a comfortable spot for her too to
answer some of the things that she's
been wanting to speak on releasing it
you know Christmas New Year's time is a
great time to bury something
um I think she got to a point where she
like had to address a lot of what's
going on for me there were there were
two things that she spoke on the first
was the Kanye stuff and
I
didn't need to hear from Kim when it
comes to the Kanye stuff like I don't
believe in holding Kim responsible or
hearing you know her condemn and I think
her explanation on that while I I didn't
need to hear it I totally understood and
I think as Children of Divorce I think
we can even appreciate it even more when
she got all choked up she basically said
like I had the greatest dad in the world
like my mom never
spoke ill of him after divorce and I'm
sure she could have divorce is hard
um and I want that so badly for my kids
and I think when they grow up and look
back on this time they will be very
grateful to me for not it's so easy she
could join in with everyone and drag him
and she didn't and I have to say I have
a lot of respect for that I don't
believe in
blaming other people for what someone
else did like this whole culture we live
in where you have to like condemn I
don't believe in that yes I agree I I
could like when I think of like Kim and
her current controversies honestly Kanye
doesn't come to mind a hundred percent I
don't care like it's not on Kim to speak
for or on her deeply unwell mentally ill
there's nothing that she could say even
if she went so hard against him that's
gonna change what he's doing and like
change the impact that he's having like
and and nobody needs that from her
especially like if you're asking like no
we don't need that right we don't care
so while I imagine that's been difficult
and I empathize I fully respect her
answer and I think that Harkins also
back to just like who Kim is as a person
like a core tenant of who she is is
family and loyalty and like I get it I
get it and I didn't need to hear on it
the thing that I found really
interesting was her take on Balenciaga
and
when I first saw the Kanye staff I'm
like okay she's like on a roll you know
ethical Queen whatever scoreboard Queen
um I so disagreed with her Balenciaga
take like
she was really just using like sound
bites and buzzwords for like cancel
culture
um
to talk about Balenciaga and like that's
not at all what was going on and at
first like I was kind of agreeing with
what she was saying like when this came
out she like wasn't really paying
attention and she didn't know why people
were bringing her into it because she
was like I looked and it wasn't a
campaign I was a part of it was before I
was even with the company and like I I
really had nothing to do with it I'm
like yeah okay I guess and then she's
like and the way like everyone just
wants to me to cancel like I don't
believe in cancel culture like all these
like click baity sound bites like that
people talk about cancel culture
which are valid when discussing cancel
culture she was just like copy and
pasting and like applying to the
Balenciaga situation and I didn't agree
with it like I really didn't it's not a
situation of cancer culture like it's
not like cancel culture is very
different like when we talk about cancer
culture we're talking about people being
held to the fire for mistakes that they
made in their past and like not even in
their past it's also just like wrong
things mistakes like things that you've
done wrong have like you know stepped
outside the box of what we want you to
say or what we want you to do and like
people can't like have their own point
of view right and so that's what cancel
culture is it's it's really more
reserved for people and it's reserved
for
um if if someone was caught out for
being a pedophile and then we like
stopped supporting them I wouldn't call
that cancel cancel culture exactly stop
supporting a pedophile so this is what
we're always saying when it comes to
cancel culture like there's such a big
difference between saying something
unpopular and doing something unpopular
like unpopular sorry not disagree bad
bad bad illegal criminal elderly wrong
so there's some there's a difference
between saying something bad and doing
something bad
correct yeah
and there's a difference between saying
something
and criminal activity like right so the
Balenciaga thing falls into the latter
category that's not cancel culture like
I don't think people want to wake up
every day and spend their hard-earned
money on a company that's subliminally
sending out messages of child
exploitation like that's not cancel
culture that's normal human life yes no
that's just the way she was using all
these buzzwords that like people love
and those clips always get shared people
really do even though it seems like
people like are always canceling normal
people don't like cancel culture and
these podcast Clips when you talk about
cancer culture they always go viral
people agree with that so she was trying
to like take that energy and place it on
the Balenciaga situation and that's not
what it is it was kind of like such a
lame answer I was like oh man this is
the best you could come up with to
defend yourself
yeah
like just I'm sure that's I'm sure
that's how she sees it though again I
think I said this like I don't think she
thinks that the people who she works
with at Balenciaga are like child
Predators so she's like oh they're just
like they came off in that way and like
We're Not Gonna Cancel them for a
mistake that they made that they
portrayed themselves in a bad light but
it's like
the um that's not a mistake the amount
of subliminal messaging like the years
it goes back like and then you know when
you really go into it like individual
people at the company like their weird
personal Instagram [ __ ] that has like
demonic satanic child stuff like it's
[ __ ] weird and still the fact like no
one has been fired no accountability
everyone's favorite word like that's
just so it's not gonna work
you know me and Ben yesterday we drove
past the valenciana store on our way
back from the airport and we were
talking like what do we think the
long-term impact of this Scandal will be
on the company and I'm curious what your
thoughts are because like I mean
there has not been a human being inside
of the Balenciaga store that I live near
in weeks like it's crazy and so
while it seems like this is the end-all
be-all I also can see a world in which
like nobody talks about anymore how like
Hugo Boss designed the Nazi uniforms and
Coco Chanel was out here having sex with
Nazis like nobody talks about that it's
just part of the fabric of the history
of these companies and I feel like years
from now this will just be like one of
balenciaga's things like these big
companies like they don't go anywhere
you know they can't be canceled yeah
years from now but if we're talking like
80 to 100 years but we will have
forgotten that Balenciaga had subliminal
child exploitation messaging in their
campaign but I'm saying oh Balenciaga
will still be like a major fashion house
like Chanel and Hugo Boss maybe because
maybe like I think they're owned by who
uh
yeah or whatever like that
because that big company can like
support you know taking the L on a name
like Balenciaga which is like a the name
itself you can't even invent today like
it's an old name with history and so
even if they like made the company
smaller for a while and then in a
generation or so like brought it back in
a bigger way with people who like don't
have the strong feelings that we have
like going through it now sure but like
and not saying that's right or wrong but
this definitely would be better than
like literally in a Year everyone having
Amnesia culture what about that and
Balenciaga sneakers are you know flying
off the shelves well then it's also like
it reminds me like John Galliano like
John Galliano was caught on tape saying
like what the Nazis were doing was
amazing and they really should have
succeeded and he really loved what they
were doing and the guests that they were
you know gassing the Jews with was
really like incredible stuff
um and he's still out here like well
he's not like he's still very like hot
polarizing and his name like if a
celebrity Wears Like A John Galliano
it's like a big deal but like he still
works I think he decides for like
margiela like he's five does he work I
believe he does
I thought he was like thoroughly
canceled I thought he was too uh but
like sometimes people might wear like a
vintage Galliano piece that's that's
different than actively working but I'm
pretty sure he's still you're right he's
been the creative director of Mason
margella
so everyone is fraudulent and nobody
actually cares about like accountability
like you could all eat my ass literally
like fashion is so problematic Beyond
this is just one of a million things and
so Balenciaga this is this is my thesis
coming to a conclusion Balenciaga will
be fine because nobody [ __ ] cares
I don't know I think they're not gonna
maybe they will their name Will Survive
this and one day be prosperous again but
I think that they are gonna have very
red in the red few years no for sure and
I'm sure John Galliano had a couple red
years too
yeah
I actually I don't know people like the
thing is even though like the media and
the fashion industry are kind of
ignoring This and like kind of
gaslighting all of us into thinking like
we're calling us conspiracy what was
that article we were talking about I
think it was a New York Times or
something or something like the
conspiracy theory about balenciagas no
and then the article called it like an
alt-right conspiracy theory right and so
like what they're all gaslighting us but
like the people and we are also the
consumers because like right the media
is not buying all this stuff I really
think the people will use their wallets
to speak out about how we are so not
here for this
I only recently saw the John Galliano
video that like I knew like John
Galliano was bad because something Nazis
like I honestly didn't bother to look
into it because I don't [ __ ] care
about fashion but it just came up on my
Tick Tock and it was honestly the
craziest thing I've ever seen in my life
yeah
same I saw most of the video recently
yeah I've never seen it
yeah and we were like really young when
it happened yeah all set to say is like
I don't think Kim's answer is sufficient
and I love myself and like I'm ready to
start standing again but she's making it
hard yeah I don't know what it's gonna
take this did nothing for me move the
moves the needle in zero way nothing the
Christmas party hasn't warmed my heart
um Kylie's Aspen outfits were amazing oh
wait she's still she's like my number
one right now and I'm not mad at her but
like I don't know what it's gonna take I
know it's I just be like in order for
her to get back in The Graces of a lot
of people she really doesn't have to do
that much and I think this podcast like
she could have just like addressed it
head on and been like you know what I
should have just stopped
um and the podcast would have been
buried with the new year like we all
could have moved on but like the way
she's
not backing down and almost doubling
down is very bizarre to me yeah cancel
culture like it was so cliche like it
was just like corny cancel culture sound
bites
yeah it wasn't the vibe no no but I I
don't know what it's going to take but I
look forward to being take this again I
look forward to being taken yeah agreed
we shall see
are you ready for our next story yeah
about unlikely
bfffffs celebrating New Years together
Nicola and Selena Nicola and Selena are
twinning on New Year's Eve and sequin
Valentino Minis and they reveal their
matching tattoos
Selena and Nicola Ann Peltz Beckham rang
in the New Year twinning with matching
dream dresses and Tattoos the singer
shared a series of sultry snaps of her
and Nicola posing in the same
long-sleeve Valentino mini sequin
dresses for New Year's and wearing the
same shoes uh they said quote I love you
my angel forever and then they showed a
picture of both of them having tattoos
they that say angel on their arms
they were sharing so much I follow them
both on Instagram I swear to God each of
them did four dumps of 10 photos like it
was insane how much footage videos and
photos from the beach and then the boat
and then the party and then this insane
amounts of footage like I was like damn
like all of us from one night this is
such a fast and furious friendship and
these celebrity friendships I feel like
when they come so hot they also burn out
so fast like I feel like I could see in
two weeks these two never talking to
each other again yeah I feel like
especially with these two people like I
I can't think of Nicola anything other
than like Bella Thorne's personal bully
and Selena like you know she's had some
celebrity friendships that she's not as
close with anymore you could go back as
far as Demi uh kidney
Francia Raisa yep the only one who stood
the test of time is Taylor but like I
just I hope they stay friends forever
I'm like loving this I'm living for the
content they're giving us so much Nicola
posted like a whole music video did you
see that one of like down on the boat
there was so much Selena content I
actually feel like for a celebrity she's
really private and I just was like does
Selena know you're putting this video
out no but then Selena was also putting
out like so much content it was just
like an insane
the volume of content to put out from
like one New Year's Eve and all of
Selena's documentary friends were there
so Raquel it's not like she's leaving
them behind no Raquel was there that was
the first I'd seen of Raquel since they
didn't not that it matters I didn't see
Selena with a man no
she was with really with like Nicola and
Brooklyn Brooklyn well and then like all
the beckhams were together and David
Beckham posted a picture of the whole
family like happy New Years at Brooklyn
Beckham Peltz we miss you not at Nicola
just at Brooklyn yeah
if you wanted to read into that you
could you could it's a little shady for
sure given what we know but like
they're with their kids and they miss
their other kid like Nicholas not their
daughter like we're with our blood and
we miss our blood no but like none of
their other kids are married so like
she's like the daughter-in-law you know
no but like say that there was no drama
between any of them at least that we
knew about Grandma and it's just like a
family posting that they miss the other
I would say I would Smoking Gun
okay no if like Ben's mom posted a photo
with her Bruce and Maddie it's different
because there's not like a gag there's
children right right but then if they
were like at boy with no job miss you
like what about me I'd be like okay
that's rude actually
I don't know I don't know I don't think
it's rude
it's rude because we know that there's
beef between the the piccolo pellets
right I don't have beef with with Ben's
parents right so it's like oh they miss
their Kim no yeah let them miss their
son in peace but if they were like boy
it was no job pups with no job right
right Jackie oh
my gosh right no that would definitely
be cause for concern
anyways um looks like they had a great
uh
a great trip great time yeah I hope this
friendship stands the test of time it's
giving me like Pete and Ariana like so
fast so Furious tattoos
tattoos tattoos is crazy but it's not
like it says like nickel and Selena it
says Nigel which you could always
repurpose
right to
um
angelic
or Angel itself I just have a new Angel
you know like you were my angel this day
I was simply leaving at their wedding
no
yeah it's a new friendship like
literally in the last month but
sometimes you just click with people you
know that's true too
a lot of there could be a lot of
different ways about this yeah no and
I'm into it like I'm into it I hope it
stands the test of time and then like
when Selena starts dating someone and
him and Brooklyn really get along and
they go golf like I love love love love
double date so I guess Selena's not
dating that guy from the summer anymore
no that was like a fling an Italian
fling romance and it was just for a
moment okay well our next story I don't
want to necessarily call this new couple
news but it could be is it the potential
new couple news that's brought to you by
ZocDoc yes it is there's nothing worse
than going to a doctor's appointment
expecting to be the center of attention
and then your doctor seems like they
have better things to do in places to be
instead of listening to you intently
asking how you feel or helping you along
the doctor's checking the clock well on
ZocDoc you're going to find quality
doctors who will focus on you listen to
you and prioritize your care ZocDoc is
the only free app that lets you find and
book doctors who are patient reviewed
take your insurance and are available
when you need them they'll treat almost
any condition under the sun
so there's no more doctors roulettes or
scouring the internet for questionable
reviews with ZocDoc you have a trusted
guide to connect to your favorite doctor
that you just haven't met yet millions
of people use zocdoc's free app to find
and book to book a doctor in their
neighborhood who's patient reviewed and
fits their needs and schedule just right
ZocDoc is perfect if you travel a lot or
if you've recently moved because once
you move and you don't have like new
dentists or your back starts to hurt
like not having those core doctors is
the worst and I feel like you'll just
delay the appointment because you don't
know where you're supposed to go so
ZocDoc is a great place to find like a
new dentist if you've moved or if you're
traveling and like you're prone to
injuries on the road like I am being
able to whip out ZocDoc and find someone
who's nearby who's available and who
takes my insurance is so valuable and
it's been really valuable for Jackie
ever since she moved to Florida so go to
zocdoc.com toast and download the ZocDoc
app for free then find and book a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that's
zocdoc.com
toast t-o-a-s-t
zocdoc.com toast
thank you mclartia you're welcome so an
unlikely friendship or more than friends
I want to get your opinion Angelina
Jolie and newly single Paul Mezcal were
spotted enjoying a coffee date after she
after she watched him perform in A
Streetcar Named Desire Angelina and Paul
were pictured grabbing a coffee together
after she watched his performance in A
Streetcar Named Desire at the Almeda
theater in London the unlikely friends
were pictured in the theater's coffee
shop where they were engaged in
conversation while surrounded by empty
tables they were also joined by
Angelina's daughter Shiloh who's 16.
Angelina by the way is 47 Paul mezcal's
26. there okay first of all we need to
backtrack because Paul Mezcal is single
and this is the craziest thing he was
engaged to Phoebe Bridgers
and then and people were like obsessed
because like Phoebe Bridgers watched
normal people and like was tweeting
about how she loved the show so much and
she was obsessed with Paul Mezcal and
they like literally met on Instagram
like during covid like he joined her
Instagram live and like she was like
living out all of our fantasies because
we all watched normal people and we're
like oh my God Paul Mezcal is so hot
they started dating they got engaged and
it was like literally like we all were
Phoebe Bridgers
then they're like rumors a couple weeks
ago that they broke up because she is
like seeing or cheated on him with Bo
Burnham
and then I was like wait what because
Bo Burnham released his special inside I
know another guy another pandemic guy
but when Phoebe was on tour she took one
of his songs
um and like made it her own and like
took it out on tour
there it is
again that funny feeling
that fun and so then like he came to her
Show when he was so excited and they
like had this really cute friendship
but now people are saying they're dating
and now he's did now I didn't even know
this next layer because I had heard this
whole story but not the Angelina Jolie
part now Paul Mezcal no I think Paul
Mezcal like
he's in this play that's being like
critically acclaimed she got tickets and
like you know celebrities go to Broadway
shows all the time I don't think that
these two are dating not only is it not
age-appropriate like I just don't see it
I agree I don't think they're dating I
think like it was like a mutual respect
coffee his daughter was there her
daughter yes but um that's what I
thought like when she was spotted out
with the weekend so I'm just a little
naive to these things maybe they're
potential business partners maybe their
potential business partners I don't know
either way like that's a really good
look for him especially if he was just
like dumped anyway yeah I don't know
like they're both like they're both so
private they don't like speak about
their
they never even like announced their
engagement they just like started
wearing a ring like they're both keep
their private lives private so I'm not
sure if we'll ever get a clarification
but I would love to know what happened
there because that was like such a cute
like like Phoebe Bridgers was like us
you know she was one of us yeah
anyway this is a good this is a really
good look for him though to be yeah I
don't not ship
I don't not ship either I just don't
believe it and I'm certainly not gonna
spend time building a ship when I
genuinely think this is just a
friendship like a date with her daughter
at Coffee it doesn't count or it's like
we've been dating for so long finally
gonna meet my daughter it doesn't light
up with the timeline no it doesn't but
oh I'm here for it I just thought it was
an interesting headline you know for
sure one I couldn't predict for 2023. no
and I hadn't even heard that but if
anyone has any extra Insight like blind
items I'm so curious about the Palms Cal
Phoebe Bridgers of it all
oh yes please help Claudia in her quest
for information because I watch normal
people too and like I was
obsessed even though like [ __ ] Sally
Rooney
I hated that show I didn't like the book
I didn't finish the show it's another
one for me like some a theme that I'm
noticing in the content is that it's so
depressing that was one of the first
shows that I felt that way about where
it was like the show is making me
depressed and I want to be happy like I
don't want to be the Press work we're
constantly trying to stay above the line
and it's a struggle why would I watch
something that's gonna bring me below it
no you're 100 right but like I could not
turn it off Paul Mezcal is a star the
story wasn't that like in like different
or whatever but he he's a star no I
could no longer take it and that's so
much of what I watched over break let's
bring those feelings on of like I'm
feeling depressed wow and this is
entertainment is supposed to be positive
entertaining like I want to see more
positive uplifting content in 2023
that's my resolution to stop I watching
things that are negatively affecting my
mental health and like no wonder there's
a mental health crisis in this country I
completely it's really it's not
everybody
everything is dark everything is twisted
everything that glorifies like
depression and suicide I completely
agree and I think like we always are
talking about the Mental Health crisis
and we're not really ever actively doing
think of anything about and I think if
like our art and our entertainment could
reflect a more and not like silence
depression because that's real but like
if everything popular is like sad then
sadness becomes popular 100 I agree we
don't need to wallow in it and I agree
to be like aspirational content like I
just feel like the movie industry is
supposed to like uplift people it does
the opposite
no and I feel like not enough is spoken
about about like the really negative
cultural impact of the show 13 Reasons
Why like nobody ever explained
themselves for that show like the way
it's so glorified and normalized suicide
and like
the way like people now say like in
popular culture it's like really common
to say this is my 13th reason like and
it's a joke but like it's not you know
what I mean like yeah I know a show did
so much damage to young people it was
literally a show that romanticized
suicide and was targeted for teenagers
a hundred percent there are a lot of
other shows like it too I think for sure
it was a big one because it's literally
13 Reasons Why I'm going to commit
suicide yeah right that was the so like
what about a show 13 reasons why you
should stay alive
yeah no other two wonderful reasons why
it's wonderful to be alive I feel like
entertainment like Hollywood like really
could be doing more and like I get it
art is twisted and it's tortured and
it's dark and there should be a corner
of the entertainment industry for that
it should be like anything else the
corner anything else that's like a big
picture where there's some of this and
there's something it's not a corner
anymore it's a whole landscape it's the
whole landscape yeah
2023 I'm gonna stop in the middle of
watching shows that are not making me
feel good just like I just watched
fleisman is in trouble depression not a
platter I finished it last night it was
so [ __ ] bad don't watch it it was
just like
it was so Dreadful and like just
existentially like I guess we're just
gonna get older and sadder until we die
yeah I never thought about my life like
that and then I was watching it last
night I was like I'm a little depressed
thinking no that [ __ ] depresses me
so
I'm gonna stop watching shows that from
the jump aren't making me feel inspired
uplifted motivated and I'm going to be
sharing more positive content with the
group love
the kopo sisters love
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story
there's only one way to ring in season
six
It's the final story
I'm Claudia and I'm saying yes to lie
faith and I'm dressing like a [ __ ]
love it our fifth and final story is
some upsetting sports news actually
again um but Martina Navratilova has
been diagnosed with two forms of cancer
I know tennis great and Real Housewives
of Miami spouse Martina Navratilova said
Monday that she's been diagnosed with
throat cancer and breast cancer in a
statement released by her representative
the 18-time Grand Slam singles champion
and member of the international Tennis
Hall of Fame said her prognosis is good
and she will start treatment this month
she said quote this double whammy is
serious but still fixable and I'm hoping
for a favorable outcome it's going to
stink for a while but I'll fight with
all I have got she said she noticed an
enlarged lymph node in her neck while
attending the season-ending WTA finals
in Fort Worth Texas in November and a
biopsy showed early stage throat cancer
while she was undergoing tests on her
throat she said the unrelated breast
cancer was discovered oh my God yeah she
had also been diagnosed with a
non-invasive form of breast cancer in
2010 and had a lumpectomy
this is so sad I love Martina like I
think she's a really smart person who
like is just what Julian needs because
Julia's like all over the place and
really annoying
um she's really like a bright spot on
the show and I obviously think like her
being on the show was like huge for the
show because she's so major in her
career
um and when I heard this I was so sad
and so devastated and I really hope
she's gonna be okay because I really
like her yeah I'm she said she's
fighting with everything that she has I
hope that you know that we all get the
outcome that a positive outcome here but
it's crazy to read this article and like
see how much she's accomplished and how
like now to house I said she's like a
wise wife yeah yeah can you read her
accomplishments it said 18 time grandson
18 time Grand Slam and then also she won
59 grand grand grand slam titles overall
including 31 in women's doubles and 10
in mixed doubles so then it was 18 in
like uh singles uh her last name her
last mixed doubles Championship with bro
Bob Ryan at the 2006 U.S open was a
month shy of her 50th birthday
oh my God Queen [ __ ] Carrie Soto wishes
no I knew her like I had heard her name
when she
um when they announced Julia when you
think of like the biggest female tennis
stars like her name is there but I never
actually looked into her accomplishments
and she's so major she's so major I
always forget about mixed doubles
I didn't even know there was a thing men
and women men and women together like so
cute so cute we love teamwork across
Jack and I play mixed doubles pickleball
I heard I heard there was an injury at
your pickleball court I heard sure there
was Shapiro couldn't handle it we've
been playing a lot of pickleball and
we've kind of been killing it Zach and I
are actually really good
um doubles like Partners we're pretty
on the same level yeah we're also good
wanna one like against each other
because we're like well matched I think
we should like maybe we should start a
league we could like make a thing of it
if we started playing in leagues and
stuff like I think we have what it takes
you know Spritz hosted a pickleball
tournament in Austin it was like a
Sprint Sprint sponsored event Ben flew
down he said it was so much fun you
should get like 10 couples and do a
tournament and like I won't be drinking
all day that's so fun yeah we should I
just need to get a little better first I
can wipe the court with them and like
make a few more friends
oh yeah that too I think we have like
six couples that's good well two of them
include you and Olivia
yes
oh okay you need to make a few more and
you and Ben will come down for the
tournament seven for sure I'll be the
referee and um halftime show
can't wait and you'll sing the national
anthem oh of course everyone will take
their hats off and respect oh you know
what I wanted to say something
so I have this feeling every time I
leave the country which I don't do often
because I'm a creature of habit and we
were talking on our trip everyone was
talking about travel they want to take
this year and I said my my number one
um
location is I want to go to Montana this
year and it shouldn't be that hard it's
like in the country and I can make it
happen but everyone was saying you know
Japan and whatever and I was talking and
explaining how I'm really like such a
creature of habit and I like love this
country and whenever I leave the country
so many so many things are different so
many little things it's not anything
major or Monumental but like it's Coke
Zero and not Diet Coke and the air
conditioning doesn't work that well and
it's just a little difference in in the
cultures that eventually by the end of
the week like I'm so [ __ ] ready to go
home and I was feeling that because they
didn't have Diet Coke they only had Coke
Zero at all the restaurants at the hotel
outside of the hotel and it was really
[ __ ] pissing me off and then I
started to notice like other little
cultural things and it's a creature of
habit like it really was annoying me and
I just wanted to come on here and say
how grateful I am to live in America
like I feel like we're always ragging on
America and we have our problems sure
but this is a great country with Daddy
coke with Diet Coke and like normal
portions and food that I'm [ __ ] used
to and you know tap that I could drink
from just from the same like I just
wanted to say I wanted to end the
episode saying I love America you're
feeling like a proud American yeah maybe
when you don't leave the country for so
long and you get you know all the
infighting I could see yeah we are not
we are not perfect we have our flaws
some of us are really [ __ ] annoying
but
whenever I leave the country it's a good
thing we've got here and it's this is
not putting down other countries at all
no because all the things that you
described as people who live in other
countries feel that way about their
country there and their portions there
are to them normal persons right so this
is not me putting down it's just my
comfort and my like you know me I'm so
stubborn I like the same things I just I
have that's my new also in New Year's
resolution like appreciate America more
I love it
I drank four Diet Cokes yesterday like
on the plane when we finally flew United
and it wasn't sure because like the
country didn't have Diet Coke they had
Coke light Coke Zia right I'm like
literally I was she ordered she's like
do you want a beverage before takeoff
I'm like do you have Diet Coke she was
like yeah I swear to God I almost cried
it was so [ __ ] delicious I'm so happy
for you yeah I've been drinking a lot of
soda I'm gonna have one for lunch today
too
look at you so it was in the Fast Five
you definitely needed to know absolutely
everything that was said here on the
show today
what we do is vital and I took you know
it took our winter break for me to
remember that yes and also I think part
of our resolutions of positivity and
positive influences in the culture is
that we also have to be that positive
influence in the culture we have to be
the other people that we wish to see
I can't think by the way I can't be
bringing people below the line I think
we have always that's actually always
been like a core principle like one of
our Scruples here at the toast is like
the world gets dark and bad but like the
toast is always going to be there for
you to make you laugh no matter what's
going on and be an uplifting and so
while we should definitely continue that
energy and have that as our New Year's
resolution that has always been like a
core tenant is that the word I keep
saying that today
um a tenant of what we do here like one
of our founding principles I totally
agree and I think that's what also we
get a lot of um accolades or people
saying you know like I was and we do it
in the toast problem I'm going through a
hard time and it's just like one hour a
day where like I'm not thinking about
negative things and that's why we do it
to keep people positive
that's what we do here and that's what
we've done today with this extra long
episode it's been so nice to be back I
feel like I still have more to say but
you know what we have a whole week and
we've got all year
we've got all year we've got all life
so
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the millennial Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up because we appreciate the accolades
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so at
Spotify iTunes Stitcher public radio I
hope we do castbox all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the toast leave a five star review about
how beautiful stunning smart and
talented we are have an amazing Tuesday
we'll see you tomorrow for hump day bye
hey love you bye